pick a 2000's movie to watch with
friends these are all so good do good
but I have to stay true with Twilight
I'm sorry Peter Pan is like maybe one of
the most important movies it's like
integral to my lore that movie is
amazing I've chosen Nation treasure on
Call of medicine I watched both National
Treasures it was the best movie to watch
W see wait maybe I need to see it I
haven't seen a bunch of these choose one
that you have se you pick National
Treasure it's good I agree you know it's
not a competition yeah it is what do you
choose oh it's definitely story yeah
trying to let everybody get their you
know I think there's only one option cuz
waiting for you is like waiting for rain
in this
drought it's so good I chose How to Lose
a Guy in 10 Days it's also very good I'm
going with Twilight what is Everett
collection no it's the credit for the
for the photo